hi guys i'm kirtana from simply learn
and welcome to this session on the top
10 it jobs
every company will be hiring for in 2021
at this point we want to remind everyone
watching that
these jobs are not in any particular
order and in our perspective are
equally important so without any further
ado let's jump right into the first job
role
big data engineer big data represents a
collection of
large volumes of data which grows
exponentially with the passing of time
and cannot be stored with the help of
traditional data management tools
that's where big data engineers come in
so
why should you become a big data
engineer according to statista
an organization specializing in market
and customer data
the global big data market is forecasted
to grow to 103 billion us dollars
by 2027 more than double its expected
market size in 2018
which means there's an abundance of
opportunities available for you assuming
you've got the right skills
next who is a big data engineer
a big data engineer is someone who
develops maintains
tests and evaluates the big data
infrastructure
the big data engineer takes into
consideration data
they can infer from the organization's
big data
and then can make decisions that can
benefit and grow the organization
so what are the skills you need to
become a big data engineer
first off programming you will need to
have hands-on experience with a
programming language
like java c plus plus or python
then we have databases you will need to
have an understanding of database
management softwares
and sql with this you have
more clarity about how the data is
managed and maintained
sql will also help you write queries for
relational database management software
for example you have options like mysql
oracle and so much more then
you need to be skilled with data
warehousing and etl
or extract transform and load process
one of the most important jobs of a big
data engineer
is to perform atl operations for this
you will need to know how you can
construct and use a data warehouse
for this you could use tools like talent
ibm data stage
informatica and so on
you will need to be experienced with
hadoop based analytics
you will need to know about technologies
like hdfs
mapreduce hive and so on
next you will need to be skilled at
apache spark
experience with processing frameworks
like apache spark
will help you deal with big data both
batch
and real-time processing you will also
need to understand the inner workings of
the popular operating systems
in the market like windows and linux to
make the best use of them
to achieve the business goals of the
organization
finally you will need to be good at data
mining and modeling
this can help pre-process and clean the
data
find trend and patterns in the data
use it for analysis
let's have a look at the average
salaries of a big data engineer in
india and the united states according to
glassdoor
in india a big data engineer can earn
approximately
783 000 rupees per annum
in the united states they can earn
approximately
103 000 dollars per annum
next let's go to our next job role
ai engineer artificial intelligence
represents
intelligence demonstrated by machines to
perform
tasks that are possible with only human
intelligence
an artificial intelligence engineer
makes it possible for a machine to do so
but why should you become an artificial
intelligence engineer
according to research by the
professional service firm pwc
an ai industry could be worth more than
15 trillion dollars
by 2030. eighty percent of emerging
technologies will have ai foundations by
2021
which is a huge endorsement to anyone
looking to start
learning and growing in this domain
so who is an ai engineer an artificial
intelligence engineer is someone
who builds and tests ai models
taking advantage of machine learning and
neural networks
with these models they are able to gain
greater insights
and are able to enable the organization
to take better informed decisions
they create ai's that are weak or strong
depending on the goals that need to be
achieved
so now let's talk about the skills
you'll need to become an ai
engineer first and foremost it's
programming skills
like with just about every job role that
you'll see in this video
some experience with programming is
mandatory
you will need to know python r java
and c plus plus just to name a few
then you will need to know linear
algebra
probability and statistics these
concepts become really important for you
to know
when you are applying different
algorithms like logistic regression
linear regression or the name base
method into your ai models
then you need to understand spark and
other big data technologies
since your work usually involves
terabytes and petabytes of data
spark and other big data technologies
like spark
hadoop cassandra and mongodb will help
you make sense out of them
next algorithms and frameworks
an understanding of how different
algorithms like knn
navis and others will help you implement
them with ease moreover
to handle unstructured data you will
need to understand deep learning
algorithms like
convolutional and recurrent neural
networks to implement them in a
framework
like pytorch thiano tensorflow
and so on finally
ai engineers must be able to use their
problem solving and communication skills
to take care of any obstacles they may
have in their path
and to help people understand their
products and ideas
so what are the responsibilities of an
ai engineer
an ai engineer converts ai
or machine learning tools into
application program
interfaces enabling other applications
to use it
models from the ground up and clearly
communicates to the organization and
stakeholders
what they stand to achieve from it they
are responsible for infrastructure that
performs data ingestion
and transformation they'll then need to
find a way to automate this
ai engineers use statistical analysis
to enable better decisions they also
will need to set up
and manage the setting up as well as
management of the ai development and
product infrastructure
so now let's talk about the salaries of
an ai engineer
according to glassdoor in india an ai
engineer can earn approximately 752
000 rupees per annum in the united
states
they can earn approximately 114 000
dollars per annum
now let's move on to our next job role
information security engineer
information security refers to a
collection of practices to ensure
an organization's data is kept secure
and protected from unauthorized access
misuse
disclosure destruction modification
and disruption an information security
engineer takes care of that
so why should you become an information
security engineer
according to cyber security ventures a
popular researcher in the field of cyber
security says that
the world will have 3.5 million
unfulfilled cyber security
jobs by the end of 2021
which means there's a world of
opportunities for people with the right
skills
so who is an information security
engineer
information security engineers is
someone who protects the organization
from cyber threats like malwares
phishing
ddos attacks and so much more
they plan and carry out measures to
protect the organization
so how do you become an information
security engineer
first off you'll need to be experienced
with common programming languages like
java c
plus plus perl and so on you'll also
need some experience with assembly
languages
then cyber security concepts you will
need to understand things
like threat modeling specifications
testing
vulnerability assessments automating
security tasks
how these can be implemented security
management practices and much
more you will also need to have an
understanding of different operating
systems
like linux and windows to determine how
they can be taken advantage of
and how you can make sure that doesn't
happen
soft skills are also very important to
an information security engineer
to help stakeholders and the team
understand problems
they can face and to ensure they take
care of it appropriately
so what are the responsibilities of an
information security engineer
first to evaluate the security needs of
the organization
and to ensure the best practices and
standards are followed
to design implement maintain oversee
and upgrade security measures
identifying all sorts of security issues
and troubleshooting them
regularly performing tests and scans to
ensure
networks and systems remain safe
handling routine daily administrative
tasks such as
reporting and keeping open lines of
communication with the organizations
appropriate departments and much more
now let's talk about the salary of an
information security engineer
according to glassdoor in india an
information security engineer can earn
approximately
697 000 rupees per annum
in the united states they can earn
approximately
99 000 per annum
next up we have data scientist data
science is a collection of
various tools algorithms and principles
that enables the extraction
of insights from data both structured
and
unstructured a data scientist works with
such
data why should you become a data
scientist
according to carrier growth website
dyson sites
backend developer 16 percent data
scientist
11 percent and software product manager
eight percent over high growth
occupations
from august to september suggesting
yet again that companies are beginning
to reorient their focus towards
longer term and larger projects that
were perhaps put on hold during
quarter one and quad two indicating a
resurgence in interest towards data
science and data scientists
so who is a data scientist a data
scientist
is someone who combines the skills of a
mathematician
scientist statistician and computer
professional to handle
large amounts of data he or she then
analyzes
processes models and interprets the data
for the use of the organization
let's now talk about the skills required
to become a data scientist
first you need knowledge regarding
databases
this is important since these will help
store and analyze data
you will need experience using tools
like oracle database
mysql teradata and more then
you will need to know about statistics
probability and mathematical analysis
these play an important role in helping
you handle complex data
you will need experience with
programming languages like r
python and sas since they play a very
important role when performing data
analysis
the languages also help when it comes to
data wrangling
you will need to master machine learning
concepts like linear and logistic
regression
svm k-means clustering and so on
you will also need to have knowledge of
big data tools such as
apache spark hadoop talon
and tableau which are used to deal with
large and complex data
which can't be dealt with using the
traditional data processing software
and finally experience with data
visualization
this enables you to represent data using
diagrams charts and graphs
let's now talk about the
responsibilities of a data scientist
a data scientist needs to be able to
determine problems with
data analytics and solutions for them
to identify data sources of value and
automate the collection of data
cleaning as well as validating
structured and unstructured data
ensuring the accuracy completeness and
uniformity of data using machine
learning algorithms to create predictive
models
and then being able to visualize their
findings in an
understandable manner now
let's talk about the salary of a data
scientist
according to glassdoor in india a data
scientist can earn approximately 10 lakh
rupees per annum
in the united states they can earn
approximately 113
000 dollars per annum
next up we have the role full stack
developer
full stack development refers to the
development of the front end
which is the client side alongside the
back end which is the server side of a
web application
a full stack developer deals with both
the front end and the back end
so why become a full stack developer
according to statista in 2021
i.t spending on enterprise software is
expected to amount
to around 492 billion us dollars
worldwide a growth of 7.2 percent from
the previous year
which means the opportunities for growth
in the domain are just
as high so who is a full stack developer
a full stack developer is someone who
works on the front end
as well as back end of a web application
let's now find the skills required to be
a full stack developer
first you will need to be skilled with
html and css
html enables you to add your content to
the websites
while css can help you alter its look
next we have programming languages you
need to be skilled with javascript as
well as other back-end languages
like sql c-sharp python and so on
an understanding of web storage and
databases will help you deal with all
the new data
you will also need to understand how to
link a database to a backend language of
your choosing
then you need experience with web
architecture
structuring your code separating and
storing particular types of
file structuring data in databases
and other concepts are really important
for you to know
an in-depth understanding of application
protocols
like http as well as https
can be hugely valuable for you
let's now talk about the
responsibilities of a full stack
engineer
a full stack developer needs to be able
to write code that's of high quality
which is well tested and devoid of
issues
he or she needs to be able to develop
databases
applications and servers to design and
develop
apis and restful services
and to create an attractive front and
infrastructure to attract an audience
let's talk about the salary of a full
stack engineer
according to glassdoor in india a full
stack
engineer can earn approximately 600 000
rupees per annum
in the united states they can earn
approximately one or six
thousand dollars per annum
let's now talk about how you can become
a network architect
a computer network connects a group of
computers enabling them to communicate
with each other
this network forms the bedrock of
everything related to i.t
a network architect sets up such a
connection
so who is a network architect a network
architect
is someone who plays an important role
in handling communication networks
like lan van and the intranet
they use their in-depth knowledge
regarding the network to ensure its
proper functioning
let's now have a look at the skills
required to become a network architect
first it is to understand the different
networking concepts
an understanding of different networks
and architectures like one
lan and so on needs to be known to
understand
how they can be integrated into the
system to satisfy business needs
next a network engineer needs to have an
understanding of the tools that will
enable them to set up
a workflow and easily identify potential
network problems
they'll need to be responsible for
managing all the major aspects of the
network
analyzing problems before they arise
troubleshooting them if they do
ensuring network safety to develop
automated functions
and much more a network architect also
needs to have some experience with
project management
an understanding of project management
concepts of budgeting
and scheduling to ensure they are able
to deliver advanced network solutions to
organizations
as usual an understanding of programming
languages
methods for virtualization and excellent
communication skills
are seen as hugely beneficial
now let's talk about the
responsibilities of a network architect
a network architect designs tests and
inspects communication systems
he or she is responsible for modeling
the network
analyzing and planning it he or she
maintains
and administers computer networks and
related environments
they analyze engineer and execute
software functions and have to set up
hardware like cables routers adapters
and so on they'll need to regularly
perform disaster recovery
and make adjustments to ensure the
network performance remains consistent
let's now talk about the salary of a
network architect
according to glassdoor in india a
network architect can earn approximately
17 lakh rupees per annum
in the united states they can earn
approximately 84
000 dollars per annum if getting your
learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
next up we are going to talk about
devops engineer
devops combines the efforts of the
operations and development teams to
deliver services
and applications at greater speed
helping products
evolve and improve at a faster rate as
compared to traditional software
management methods
why become a devops engineer according
to the devops
institute 42 percent of global
enterprises are applying devops
at the project or multiple project level
which means
they are looking for skilled individuals
to take up that responsibility
an individual like a devops engineer
let's now talk about who is a devops
engineer a devops engineer
is someone who coordinates with both the
development
and the operations team in an
organization
thanks to their deep understanding of
the software life cycle
he or she uses this collaboration
between teams
to oversee or facilitate product
releases
and perform deployments in the manner of
continuous integration
or deployment now
for the skills required to become a
devops engineer
first a devops engineer needs to have an
understanding of scripting in languages
like python and ruby enabling you to
provision
and manage infrastructure you will need
experience handling devops tools
like chef ancebel and pipette to ensure
that the customer is able to gain value
from the product
at a fast pace and with greater quality
next to deliver products at such a fast
pace
and understanding of continuous delivery
and integration is mandatory
a devops engineer also needs soft skills
to ensure
you build an aura of trust understanding
and camaraderie among the teams and
their team members
you will also need to have an
understanding for cloud computing
since it provides a platform to test
deploy and release
code now let's talk about what the
responsibilities of a devops engineer
are
understanding the customer's
requirements and the project's
key performance in this is to implement
different infrastructure for development
testing automation tools
id infrastructure and so on
to manage stakeholders and external
interfaces
setting up the appropriate tools and
infrastructure
and to review verify and validate code
developed in the project
to mentor and guide the team members and
to measure customer experience and kpis
and to the periodic reporting on
progress and more
let's talk about the salaries of a
devops engineer
according to glassdoor in india a devops
engineer can earn approximately
700 000 rupees per annum
in the united st
up let's talk about cloud engineer cloud
computing is the system of delivering
computing services
including servers storage databases
networking and so on a cloud computing
engineer will help take advantage of
these platforms
so why should you become a cloud
engineer according to
forester the market research company
the global public cloud infrastructure
market will grow 35
percent to 120 billion dollars
in 2021 and with the right skills
you can make the most of this growth by
becoming a cloud engineer
so who is a cloud engineer a cloud
engineer is responsible for handling
the many technological aspects of cloud
computing
including design planning maintenance
and support let's talk about the skills
required to become a cloud engineer
first off you will need to have
experience with cloud computing
platforms
be it aws azure or the google cloud
platform
you can also learn about these
certifications with the help of
certifications
you can find across the internet if
you're interested
you can check out our cloud computing
full course by clicking on the top right
corner
next you need to have experience with at
least one programming language
like c c plus plus python java
and so on and finally you will need to
specialize
in some of the services offered by the
cloud computing platform
like storage and networking security and
disaster recovery
web services and so much more
now let's talk about the
responsibilities of a cloud
engineer a cloud engineer needs to
collaborate with other teams to
determine the optimal cloud solutions
to plan design and develop cloud
applications
to deploy and debug new cloud
initiatives
to manage cloud environments according
to the security guidelines of the
organization
to make sure the application's
performance uptime
and scale have to maintain the high
standards of the code
to define and document the best
practices and strategies for application
deployment
as well as infrastructure maintenance
and much more
next let's talk about the salary of a
cloud engineer
according to glassdoor in india a cloud
engineer can earn approximately
544 000 rupees per annum
in the united states they can earn
approximately one hundred and
eleven thousand dollars per annum
now let's talk about the job role
robotics engineer
robotics refers to a collaboration of
science
engineering and technology to enable the
use of machines to do
things that humans cannot or are not
willing to do
a robotics engineer thrives in this
field
why should you become a robotics
engineer according to statistar the
market demand of advanced robotics in
the manufacturing industry
is expected to grow at a compound annual
growth rate of 46 percent over the next
four years
to reach 3.7 billion us dollars by 2021.
now that we know the potential of this
field let's ask the question
who is a robotics engineer a robotics
engineer is someone who creates robots
to fulfill a particular need
these needs are usually things that
humans cannot do by themselves
or aren't willing to do so
so what are the skills required to
become a robotics engineer
first you will need programming skills
in javascript
python c or c plus plus java
and much more a clear understanding of
languages will help you set up
interactions with hardware
electronics and the real world with ease
you will need to be good at math and
science
algebra calculus geometry physics
applied mathematics and more to make
sure
to help create equations and formulas
to help your robot move and so on you
will need experience with
microprocessors
since they act as the necessary
components to create prototypes
and you will need experience working
with sensors
since they are used to observe the
environments around the robot
being experienced with machine learning
algorithms also can be extremely useful
for you
now let's talk about the
responsibilities of a robotics
engineer a robotics engineer designs
builds tests and maintains prototypes
you will need to design systems to
control robot systems
analyze and evaluate robot prototypes
to perform integration tests and quality
control
applying appropriate machine learning
techniques and much
more next up we have the salary of a
robotics engineer
according to glassdoor in india a
robotics engineer can earn approximately
364 000 rupees per annum
in the united states they can earn
approximately 75 000 dollars per annum
finally we have the blockchain developer
blockchain refers to a system that
enables the recording of information
in a way that's impossible to change
hack or cheat the system
it is a ledger of transactions that's
distributed across the network
on the blockchain a blockchain developer
sets up
and takes advantage of this system
so why should you become a blockchain
developer
according to globe news network
the global blockchain market sized grow
at a
cagr rate of over 69 percent between
2019
to 2025. now
let's find out who is a blockchain
developer
a blockchain developer designs
implements and supports a blockchain
network
and distributed applications now
let's talk about how to become a
blockchain developer
first you will need to be well versed
with programming languages like java
c plus plus javascript go
python and so on these languages can be
used for coding and to create web
apps you will need to understand the
fundamentals of object-oriented
programming
as well as data structures like stack
linked list
queue and so on you will also need to
have knowledge regarding web app
development enabling you to create web
and mobile apps based on blockchain
technology
you will need to have experience with
flight and relational databases
since the basis of the entire blockchain
system exists
thanks to these concepts
experience with networking can also be
highly beneficial for you
now let's talk about the
responsibilities of a blockchain
developer
you will need to design the blockchain
protocols
you will need to design the network
architecture that can be used for the
centralizing or decentralizing the data
you are in charge of back-end
development according to the blockchain
protocols
and developing the front-end designs
according to client requirements
and much more let's now talk about the
salary of the blockchain developer
according to glassdoor in india a
blockchain developer can earn
approximately
783 000 rupees per annum
in the united states they can earn
approximately 72 000
per annum and there you go that's
our list we've now reached the end of
this video
think we've missed anything important
let us know in the comment section below
do not forget to subscribe click on the
bell icon to never miss an update on
simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here